which Cameo and Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness will leave fans
who aren't Comics readers scratching
their heads and which one will make Sam
Raimi fans scream with delight keep
watching for our ranking from worst to
best as you might suspect it's all
spoilers from here
in the mid-credits scene of Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness Dr
Strange is greeted on the street by a
woman in purple with long blonde hair
insisting he go with her to fix a new
multiversal incursion this character
played by Charlize Theron gets no real
introduction which is sure to confuse a
lot of viewers not familiar with the
doctor strange Comics the credits
confirm that Theron's character is Clea
who hails from the dark dimension and is
nice of dormammu given the character's
romantic history with Dr Strange there's
certainly plenty of potential for CLIA
to be a great character in future movies
and the idea of Theron joining the MCU
might be enough of a tease for viewers
who don't read Comics but that doesn't
make the Cameo itself any more coherent
rintra is a green Minotaur and one of
the sorcerers at kamartaj while he may
be more of a minor supporting character
than a cameo exactly his presence is odd
enough to elicit the same sort of who is
that response since renshra receives no
proper introductions some viewers might
wonder if they forgot him from the first
Doctor Strange movie but neither he nor
any member of his alien species have
appeared in the MCU before now he's just
there because Marvel had the extra
effects budget for a CGI Minotaur it
seems in a way it's kind of impressive
that Marvel Studios has made audiences
so accustomed to comic book weirdness
that a giant green Minotaur alien can
show up without even being remarked upon
the robots at the Illuminati
headquarters don't look exactly like the
Ultron MCU fans are familiar with but
one of them can be heard making commands
in the name of Ultron when Scarlet Witch
first makes her attack the credits
confirm these robots are indeed meant to
be alternate universe versions of Ultron
played by the characters what if voice
actor Ross Marquand there are worlds
beyond my own worlds that needs me the
alternate ultron's presence does present
some interesting World building for this
alternate universe clearly they didn't
try to kill all humans like the one in
Age of Ultron so one has to wonder how
they came to be were they created by
Tony Stark like on Earth 616 perhaps
they were a project of Reed Richards and
the Baxter Foundation or maybe they're a
Hank Pym creation like in the original
comics
on Earth 616 Maria Rambo was Carol
danver's best friend on Earth One
Division revealed she died of cancer
during the blip so it's nice to see her
again as the Captain Marvel of the
Illuminati Universe like all the members
of the Illuminati she's killed by
Scarlet Witch fairly easily and her
death is perhaps the most frustrating of
the bunch director Sam raimi's
willingness to risk fan anger by killing
off characters is one of the strong
points of Multiverse of Madness but the
way Rambo's death is handled is pretty
weak Captain Marvel is supposed to be
one of the strongest superheroes around
yet this version of her is simply
dispatched by a falling statue surely
there could have been a more intense and
scary death scene that didn't minimize
her power
what if built up Captain Carter a Peggy
Carter variant who took the super
soldier serum instead of Steve Rogers to
be a key character given the appearances
of her shield and trailers it's not
particularly surprising but still really
cool to see Haley Atwell get a chance to
play Captain Carter in live action in
Multiverse of Madness like the other
Illuminati members Captain Carter's
screen time is fairly brief but it's
structured effectively with a fun action
scene paralleling Rogers famous I'm
gonna do this all day moment she's
killed in the most brutal and ironic way
possible by her own Shield
these short-lived Inhumans TV show was a
pretty Infamous flop so seeing Anson
mount's Black Bolt show up as part of
the Illuminati comes as a surprise
Bolt's emergence from a rare MCU misstep
might be why strange seems to Target him
with his sardonic humor his death also
makes him seem not too bright black
Bolt's words can kill in a flashback to
the Illuminati dispatching their
universe as Doctor Strange it's his I'm
sorry that finishes him off this power
is turned against him by Scarlet witch
who cleverly removes his mouth just as
he is about to speak the sound gets
locked inside his skull which explodes
from the inside
casting John Krasinski as Mr Fantastic
and Multiverse of Madness is either the
ultimate fan service or the ultimate
troll there's no official word of who
will play Reed Richards in the
forthcoming Fantastic Four MCU entry but
casting Krasinski here matches up with
some of the most popular fan casts this
version of Mr Fantastic doesn't last
long he's the second Illuminati member
killed by Scarlet Witch when she
essentially shreds his body into string
cheese if Krasinski indeed returns as
the Reed of Earth 616 this could be an
unorthodox introduction to one of the
next great MCU Heroes like John Travolta
and Pulp Fiction audiences will have
watched him die well before his story is
over
rather than reprising the Incarnation of
the character he played in the fox X-Men
films Patrick Stewart seems to be
playing the version of Professor X from
the 90s X-Men animated series given the
design of his chair and the music that
plays during his introduction
Stuart as Xavier is a perfect bit of fan
service which will appeal to multiple
generations of Marvel fans the
characters psychic powers make him
seemingly the ideal match to face the
mental manipulations of the Scarlet
Witch if any of the Illuminati could win
the battle against her it would have
been him which makes his death all the
more intense and upsetting
for all the Marvel fan service scattered
throughout Multiverse of Madness the
best thing about the movie is just how
strongly director Sam raimi's
sensibility shines throughout there's
wild cinematography wacky fun house
horror and of course a cameo from Bruce
Campbell Campbell made his big break as
Ash Williams the hero of raymie's Evil
Dead series and the actor continues to
play ridiculous Parts in the director's
other films his part in Multiverse of
Madness is a parallel universe Pizza
ball salesman named Pizza Papa whom Dr
Strange afflicts with a curse that
forces him to beat himself up in a clear
Evil Dead reference the film's
post-credits scene catches up with pizza
Papa as the curse finally wears off a
funny bit that's also strangely
satisfying
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more Looper videos about
the MCU are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the Bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]